most machines of any degree of
complexity that we opt to live around
are offered to us with an instruction
manual a guide to how the unfamiliar
machine works what we can expect from it
how to get the best out of it and how to
interpret its signals the assumption
being that it will be so much easier and
less enraging to deal with this machine
when we have taken some time
systematically and patiently to learn
how it operates and yet one area where
we tend not to have manuals to read is
when it comes to other people and their
functioning this causes us immense
troubles we go into relationships
without any real sense of where the
others peculiarities will lie and vice
versa we unwittingly proceed as if
operating another person might be an
intuitive skill we'll just pick up along
the way it can take a painful decade or
more to work out the very basics mostly
human machines work in extremely odd
ways and yet tend not to explain the
origins of their madness
for example they don't calmly lay out
that certain incidents in childhood have
given them a disposition to shout at
airports to be suspicious of Authority
or to be shifty in owning up to debts we
must work backwards from outward
behavior to possible causes without any
help from the machines themselves
sometimes the signals are just
completely confusing off I really
don't want to see you turns out to mean
I'm so worried you don't want me and I'm
getting in early with my revenge please
tie Leah wear your clothes and put away
the dishes might mean I'm trying to
control you procedurally because I feel
so out of touch with you emotionally we
would save so much time if we knew how
to give one another manuals early on if
we could explain when I'm hurt I go cold
or I'm especially prone to be
subservient
but then resentful or I get brutal when
I'm at my most vulnerable or I feel a
need to talk about other possible lovers
because I feel so unattractive to you
deep down in
the weaknesses of machines are usually
discovered in a heat of conflicts in
contexts where they would have wounded
the other person and therefore will be
denied the goodwill that might have
ensured they could be forgiven
many of the difficult patterns of
behavior of human machines have very
sympathetic points of origin but once
they have caused the partner humiliation
they are unlikely ever to be looked upon
charitably we don't need people to be
perfect we only need them to be able to
see their faults to teach us about them
when we are unthreatened and to
apologize for the difficulties they
caused us in good time in other words
the greatest most loving and luxurious
gift any partner could ever give another
is an instruction manual to their own
rather tortured odd but ultimately
always really rather lovable soul
you